s
en place, des digues de sable
aussi érigé.
Les résidents ne savent pas
réintégrer leur résidence.
- Dans le fond, ça
c'est ma chambre avec- Alex Gags
membres de sa famille n'ont eu
que quels pour quitter
leur maison. Ils ont amené
que le strict nécessaire.
ALEX GAGNON
aucune garantie que la maison...
on va pouvoir réintégrer
ile, là, on est même pas
capable de retourner chercher
du matériel, accompagnés ou non.
- Une trentaine de familles
actuellement aucun endroit
leur paye l'hébergement.
La soeur d'Alex, Megan, a dû
aux. Ils sont hébergés
dans une animalerie.
GAGNON
- Ça me fait de la peine, mais
t'sais, tout le monde estFait qs
ça se remplace. Les animaux,
mes parents, mes frères et
soeurs, tout le mo
- Un glissement de terrain
est inévitable, selon la ville.
Et les résidents autour
du secteur condamné craigentne .
GEENY EMOND
- Je me dis que c'est hors
de mon c rien de s'en
soucier trop.
le reconnaissent :
les compensations actuelles
ne sont pas suffisantes.
JULIE DUFOUR, mairesse Saguenay
- Quelques 200 000 $ en
pour se loger par jour, vous
comprendrez que dans le contexte
actuel, ça ne tient pas
la route. Donc il y a déjà
des communications avec
pour adresser un programme.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Les programmes qui existentnie
quelqu'un qui perd sa maison,
dans une comme ça,
a droit à 260 000 $.
210 000 pour la maison,
50 000 pirede le bonifier. On te
aussi avec la maîtresse Julie
Dufour, avec la Croix-Rouge
pour ê
un logement puis aider
financioutes
les familles.
- En après-midi, la Sécurité
publique a tenu une rencontr
d'informations avecles sinistré.
préliminaire. C'est vraiment
juste pour l'aide financièrede .
- Il y a rien de nouveau que
moi, en fait, je ne connaissais.
de façon ode façon ode façon od,
mais c'est le même montant
que les autres.les lèvres : poun
réintégrer un jour leur maison?
- C'est  années
qu'on a passées dans
le sentiment d'appartenance,
c'est les souvenirs...c'est l'i.
Ici Mare Rochon,
si Radio-Canada,